الشرير الرئيسي في سلسله البطاقيه هاري
وميغن او على الاقل الجزء الاول منها هو
وسائل الاعلام البريطانيه وليس العائله
الملكيه دعونا نتعرف على اهم النقاط في
الحلقات الثلاثه الاولى هاري يقول ان
الجميع ذكريات طفولته لا تخلو من وجود
مصوري الفراتي يطاردونه منذ ايامه في
المدرسه وحتى بدايه علاقته بزوجته
ظهرت الوثائقي وتحدثت لاول مره عن علاقه
ابنتها وهاري وتعتقد ان الاعلام يحمل
طابعا عن سوريا
الثقه ويقول ان استمراره في الاعمال
الخيريه نابع من الحفاظ على ارث والدته
تتريقتنا اللقاءها الاول بالملكه وهجمت
بسبب تلك اللقطه تحديدا واتهمت بالسخريه
من التقاليد الملكيه لكن البعض راى انها
تتحدث بشكل عفوي لا
ورغم الانتقادات الا انا اخرين يعتقدون ان
المسلسل اظهر ان هاري وميغن يشبهان اي شخص
اخر خاصه مع استخدام ارشيف الشخصي من
مقاطع وصور وفيديو لثنائي